grab your best ball gown and gear up for
a whole lot of crazy because we're
breaking down Riverdale's season 3
finale on Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
hey river babes
I'm your host Leonid Galera and it's so
good to see you one last time for our
final Sweetwater secrets after-show as
we discuss episode 322 chapter 57
survive the night now I'm the only one
who's bringing you exclusive answers
straight from Starr Camilla Mendez
talking all about the shocking
flash-forward scene at the end of the
finale and as always I'll be dishing my
kisses and kisses but first take a deep
breath and get ready for a whole lot of
drama as I try to explain the super
complicated episode in the blue and gold
breakdown now the finale kicked off with
Penelope being a poisonous little spider
after getting all the information from
recently escaped Tony and then drugging
her daughter's BAE the blossom matriarch
went straight to Edgar Evan ever and
stopped him from hacking into her niece
Betty boo dear but if you thought
Penelope was the savior here think again
what each of our core for yes even safe
and sound Betty received lavish
invitations from The Gargoyle King
inviting them to a fancy dinner party at
the blossom family hunting lodge which I
had no idea existed what is this place
and now here's where it gets really
tricky so pay attention
Penelope also invited her minions to
dinner the undead nun sister Woodhouse
the black hood Hal Cooper and of course
the gargoyle king who was finally
revealed to be chick pretending to be
Jason blossom to please deluded Penelope
since when does chicka fright hair Oh
chick it doesn't matter how many twigs
you hold up you cannot pull off the
ginger look
turns out the black hood didn't kill
chick duh but instead Hal took him under
his serial-killer wings and then when
Penelope blossom was manipulating how
with her womanly ways the three of them
teamed up to be what I'm now calling the
twisted trifecta of evil you're not now
Penelope claims she orchestrated all of
these murders because she was grieving
the death of her son and because years
ago she was adopted into the blossom
family as a quote child bride and she
was furious at the town of Riverdale for
letting it happen
Riverdale yes twisted and cursed just as
the cord discovered the spider's web of
G and G both past and present led back
to Penelope aka the true gargoyle queen
she revealed that she had one more
deadly quest for our foursome I'd start
running if I were you so here's what
they had to do the red paladin aka
Archie had to battle a grizzled beast
because of course he did and then Archie
somehow survived yet another ultra
brutal fight part one complete are you
sure you're okay next up Veronica had to
play a poisonous round of
spin-the-bottle / Russian roulette but
Betty tag-teamed the quest with her
because friendship love you
turns out all the chalices were filled
with a slow poison but the antidote
could only be obtained at the end of the
quest because of course they talked as
for Jughead well he had to battle chicks
n' who apparently prefers to be
shirtless when he brawls Wow okay you're
no Archie babe so just calm down not
gonna happen bro
anyways Jughead easily knocked him out
with a satisfying thud and the gang
pressed onward as for Betty's mission
well she had to come face-to-face with
her father and she was then faced with a
gun and a truly twisted situation you
have till the count of three either
shoot me or I'll shoot you Betty didn't
even wait till three
she swiftly shot her psychotic father in
the chest and just as we all were
thinking hey this is Riverdale I'm sure
how is gonna survive again a disgruntled
Penelope walked up and finished the job
useless
yeah I don't think you can come back
from that one how ye they grabbed the
antidote and just as the gang thought
that their a hellish game was over
Penelope's thirst for death and betrayal
took over kill them all meanwhile with
alice's help cheryl was able to escape
the farm with davey juniper and then
right on cue Nana rose woke up Tony
because she's always there for her
there's no time Antoinette with Shoni
back together and Nana's new information
the rescue team assembled it's at the
core fort
raced through the woods looking like
they just escaped another prompt from
hell Tony and Cheryl are crimson Archer
led the serpents and poisons rescue
party
Betty then raced over to the farm to
rescue her mom but all that was left was
a whole bunch of shoes and sweet baby
Kevin they left me
according to jugheads ominous voiceover
we've realized that chicks in jail but
Penelope escaped in the town was trying
to get back to normal Oh sounds a little
dull well kinda because side note while
Cheryl was in the farm searching for the
body parts that Betty told her about our
redheaded babe finally discovered how
Edgar has been letting her communicate
with her brother brace herself she's
been talking to Jason blossoms dead
corpse that was robbed from his grave
but rather than oh I don't know putting
him back Cheryl had a new plan welcome
home JJ yeah meanwhile Hermione was
arrested because even from jail Hyrum
still runs this town damn it you don't
even know what's coming here and a new
FBI agent showed up to reveal that Alice
wasn't the brainwashed farmy we all
thought she was mm-hmm
she was actually working undercover from
the inside to try and take Edgar down
and save Polly and if you thought that
FBI fella looked familiar well then
you're in luck he's Charles the
half-brother of Betty and the
half-brother of Jughead
lastly the core form met up it pops to
celebrate the end of their craziest
chapter yet and make a vow to have a
completely normal senior year and just
as we were about to cry happy tears at
the thought of season four being more
like season one Riverdale slapped us out
of our happiness with the flash-forward
from hell
can anyone freak out out there okay you
gotta keep our composure during their
Spring Break of their senior year Betty
Archie and Veronica are standing in
their skivvies covered in blood as Betty
tells Archie to burn jugheads beanie to
it
she then gives instructions that sounds
like they're now in an episode of how to
get away with murder that is the only
way that we won't get caught
looks like we've got another year of
crazy ahead of us but if you're
wondering why Veronica didn't have any
lines in that scene well that's because
cami Mendes was waiting to spill all the
Chi or should I say milkshakes
exclusively to me let's talk about the
flash-forward oh when you read that in
the script what was your initial
reaction scared I'm like what what's
happened here what have we done but I
think it's like perfect tedious for the
next season and I'm curious to see what
it all means
how much has roberto filled you in on
what's coming up zero as per usual do I
really have no idea Wow
well well we're all still trying to
process with that let's go over our last
romantic moments of the season in seven
seconds in heaven in the middle of their
gng quest archie confessed his love for
Veronica again but then she revealed
that she made a mistake by picking
Reggie the night of the fight I love you
I love you Archie can't they sealed
their rekindled moment with a sweet kiss
and it was like you could almost forget
about the fact that they were being
hunted through the woods and being
forced to finish deadly missions
I can't even it's literally not possible
now Bart she wasn't the only couple to
share a sweet smooch Shonen greeted each
other with a sultry embrace that naina
rose happily approved of
and then bug-head also had one last
tender moment together I love you I love
you too overall there's no denying that
this was our least romantic season of
Riverdale but let's try to focus on the
bright side so shout out your favorite
swooner the moments of the year in the
comments below and now let's move into a
quick round of hisses and kisses kicking
us off this episode was a lot to process
heck this season was a whole lot of
crazy so I don't have too many hisses to
give out to this finale and that could
just be because I'm just so relieved
it's all over but I will give a little
hiss to the fact that Archie had to
fight that beast Man Thing and that he's
somehow won Oh and hisses to Hyrum just
because I don't know it's tradition at
this point this traditions been in my
family going back generations and hisses
- Penelope's deep grudges that caused
this whole mess in seasons 1 through 3
you need therapy babe and I'm irritated
that you're still out there because that
means you're eventually going to come
back that may or may not be true and yes
ok I'll dish out another hiss to the
fact that Sherrill is now playing house
with her dead brother's corpse because
seriously what the hell is going on red
actually that kind of tracks which leads
us to kisses kisses - that brief Spring
Break scene whoa whoa now before all you
Jughead lovers start yelling at me for
treason here I'm definitely not happy
that jug is missing from that group in
my opinion Cole Sprouse is one of these
strongest parts of this show but I'm
actually intrigued by the scene which
hasn't happened in a while seriously it
felt grounded by Riverdale standards
that is and it seemed like a scene that
could have happened in season 1 which is
the season that we all so desperately
miss so I'm cautiously optimistic for
how this will all play out the face
kisses to Alice for proving to us that
she's not actually the worst mother in
the world
she's actually kind of amazing to see
Polly and kisses to the introduction of
the real Charles I have no idea how he's
actually alive but he looks so much like
a combo between Lily Reinhart and Cole
Sprouse that at this point I'm too
mesmerized to really question it
what choice do you have kisses to the
last three kisses we got from our top
three couples
bug-head Shoni and barchi and kisses to
the hopes that sweet baby kevin will
actually get a storyline next year why
the hell not I'm also going to give
kisses to Riverdale for wrapping up all
this G&G and the farm nonsense and tying
it all back to Jayson blossoms murder of
season one in the black hood of season
two was it perfect no am I glad it's
over
yes so in my tired opinion that deserves
a kiss oh my god of course and we're
going to end it there now before I bid
you adieu and wish you all a very happy
summer I wanted to take the time to
thank you river babes for all of your
hisses kisses comments theories and
cliques that you have so graciously
shared with me on sweet water secrets
like I've said before it takes a lot of
my time and energy and yes even my
sanity to bring you two episodes of
sweet water each week so I want to take
a moment to thank my amazing crew Rick
Erik and Rigo for all of their hard work
this year and a massive thank you to my
incredibly talented editor Hank who
pulls all-nighters every week to make
these after shows so fun and fantastic
to watch oh wow this season was filled
with so many ups and downs and miss you
Luke but we were able to get through it
all as a fandom and I really love you
river waves we're always keeping the
comments such a positive place to be so
on that note thank you again so much for
watching Sweetwater secrets this season
and if you had fun with me please give
this video a like and then hit the
comments below with your top hisses and
kisses of the year
love you river wave so much bye
you
[Applause]
[Music]